iris modernist coronavirus vaccine is
now becoming available
yeah john that starts this morning the
distribution does it's now the second
coven vaccine uh following pfizer's just
a couple weeks ago bianca holmen live
this morning at the southern nevada
health district with more about this new
vaccine hi bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so the fire vaccine arrived here at the
southern nevada health district last
week
and so moderna the vaccine it will be
coming very very soon and be distributed
just like the pfizer one was to local
hospitals here in the area
now modern is the second vaccine to be
authorized for emergency use by the fda
after pfizers earlier this month it will
be quickly
shipped via ground and air routes to 3
700 hot spots in all 50 states
the two vaccines have some similarities
and differences both require two shots
however the moderna vaccine can be
stored in regular refrigerators
and has a longer shelf life which is
helpful for rural communities
more than 272 thousand americans mostly
those hospital workers and front line
workers have received the first
of two pfizer shots the moderna vaccine
is also another sign of hope
a glimmer of hope that we're racing
toward the end of the pandemic as
quickly as possible
many feeling the same way the cdc
recommends that people 75 and older
and essential workers like firefighters
teachers and grocery store workers be
next in line
for the coronavirus vaccine now members
of congress they received their vaccine
last week president-elect biden and his
wife will receive theirs
later today reporting live from the
southern nevada health district bianca
holman 8 news now